welcome to pymol 101 with molecular
memory today we'll be learning about the
molecular interactions that stabilize
secondary structure
we'll use the structure from last time
these proteins interact to modulate the
movement of bacterial flagella
and as an added bonus they contain all
the basic secondary structure elements I
want to teach you about
load the structure as usual one a zero o
and display the sequence now color by
secondary structure
we're going to keep coming back to this
view to explore the different types of
secondary structure in this model so
let's save a scene
drop down menu store F1
right click on F1 and rename it I'll
call it overall
we'll explore an alpha Helix first
let's rotate and try to find the longest
one
maybe this one
click on a residue in the helix
notice how we see a highlight on the
sequence display but the scroll bar is
outside of it
scroll until we can see the residues
we've selected
great now let's expand our selection by
clicking and dragging over the other
residues that make up this red colored
helix
now one of my favorite command combos
s-e-l-e h unselected
then rename the selection to Helix to
save it
helices have distinct hydrogen bonding
patterns involving their backbone atoms
which Primal calls the main chain we'll
need to see the oxygen and nitrogen
atoms to show this
let's color the Helix with CPK coloring
and show sticks
I'm going to make sure my n-terminus is
on top by clicking on the leftmost amino
acid in the sequence
and Center it
all the backbone carbonyls C double bond
o groups now Point downward
they'll hydrogen bond to a nitrogen atom
of another amino acid if it's an alpha
Helix the hydrogen bonding will follow
an i plus 4 pattern this means the
residue closer to the n-terminus
hydrogen bonds to the residue that's
four positions away
for example if it's residue 100 it'll
hydrogen bond to residue 104. let's add
these backbone backbone interactions
find polar contacts just intra main
chain
okay
it's more than expected but it's hard to
see anything at all
let's start by hiding the cartoon
still pretty busy and overwhelming
since it's only the main chain
interactions we're looking for let's
also hide the amino acid side chains
okay that's better now let's analyze a
residue making only one contact to
determine the type of Helix
click on the two interacting atoms and
the residues will highlight in the
sequence
it's k122 interacting with k126
122 plus 4 is 126. so this is indeed an
alpha helix
we're also just seeing some secondary
close contacts with all these lines
let's produce an image that shows only
the main stabilizing interactions for an
alpha Helix now we don't want all these
secondary measurements we can use the
measurement wizard to pick only the
interactions we want to show in the drop
down menu wizard measurement
we can now Trace over the vertically
oriented I plus 4 interactions
when we deselect the main chain polar
contacts we see the I plus four
interactions we've measured
if we measure the whole Helix they're
going to be a lot of measurements that
fill up the whole names panel we've got
a couple options to neaten this up
you can group objects in the names panel
so let's take measure one a
group
new group
now let's add measurement two and three
to the group
now we can operate on the grouped
objects together
let's recolor them
there's another way to achieve this that
I really like but if you miss click
you'll have to start over
first let's delete our grouped object
now the purple parts of the measurement
wizard have built-in menus click on
create new object and change this to
merge with previous now I'll start where
we did before for the first measurement
then carefully rotate to capture the
others
notice there's just one measurement in
the names panel and we're adding to it
let's rotate and try to measure them all
okay I think we've got them click done
and now we have one clean object that
I'll rename to Helix measure
a lot of work went into that rendering
let's save a scene
I'll call my scene Helix now let's use
the scene we saved before to go back to
the overall structure
reposition the structure to show one of
the sheets and save a quick scene
arrows that appear on sheets in Primal
Point toward the c-terminus
notice the strands of the sheet run in
opposite directions
now let's compare this to the other
sheet in the structure
they're running in the same direction
this type of beta sheet is called
parallel
let's go back to the first sheet using
our scene
this one is called anti-parallel the
anti indicates the sheets are running in
opposite directions let's dig into these
sheets to see what this means
structurally click on one amino acid in
it and use that to locate the Strand in
the sequence
okay the sheet we want is in chain B
select all of the yellow amino acids by
clicking and dragging on them in the
sequence
hide unselected and then rename this
selection anti
show sticks and color with CPK coloring
oh when I try to move this it's a little
wonky so let's use the a button to
Center the selection notice where the
side chains are relative to the backbone
atoms
then hide the side chains and the
cartoon
Now find
polar contacts just intra main chain
there they are
notice again these are between a
carbonyl oxygen and the NH of the
backbone nitrogen we don't see the
interacting hydrogen atoms go ahead and
save a scene
onto the parallel sheet
return to our main scene and click on a
residue within it find it in the
sequence
and then select all yellow residues in
chain a
hide unselected
save the selection by renaming it
and then Zoom
show sticks and apply CPK coloring
again we'll use polar contacts to show
the hydrogen bonds
actions find
polar contacts just intra main chain
hide the side chains and hide the
cartoon
now save a scene called parallel
using the stick rendering the way we can
tell this is a parallel data sheet is by
examining the amide linkages
also called peptide bonds in a protein
look for the carbonyl on one strand
and find the nitrogen directly bonded to
it
it's on the left in this View
now look at another chain
this nitrogen is also on the left
the nitrogens are on the same side of
the carbonyls so the strands are running
in the same direction this is a parallel
beta sheet return to the anti-parallel
scene now and repeat this analysis on
this strand that's positioned near the
top the nitrogen is to the right of the
carbonyl
on the next strand here's a carbonyl
and the adjacent nitrogen is on the left
the strands run in opposite directions
in this anti-parallel beta sheet and
that's our lesson on measurement and
secondary structure I hope you learned
something